دونا كلل ولا ملل تظاهرات حشيده في عده
مدن ايرانيه لم تخفض اصواتها منذ ان بدات
وقودها مواطنون كالمعيشه وقمع النظام
للشباب والمراهقين وحتى الاطفال
النظام الايراني يدركه حجم المعضله امامه
حلوله لم تكن كثيره في صديق تظاهرات
اعتمدت بشكل رئيسي على العنف المفرط
والترهيب بسلاح الاعدام كاداه للقمع
السياسيه حسب صحيفه واشنطن بولت
ثلاثه مراهقين يخضعون للمحاكمه في احدى
ضحى طهران مع عشرات اخرين بتهمه قتل ضابط
شرطه
عقوبه مغلظه كالاعدام التي تلاحق اولئك
المراهقين تاتي بسبب اتهامهم بجرائم تتعلق
بالاحتجاجات الاخيره
يمثل المراهقون الثلاثه امام المحكمه
الثوريه وهي فرع يختص بالحكم في قضايا
الامن القومي وليس من اختصاصها الفصل في
قضايا الجنائيه ضد القصيرين جماعه حقوقيه
تؤكد ان العقوبات التي طالت المراهقين
تاتي ضمن اطار تسعيدي جديد لحمله وحشيه
الهدف منها ترهيب الشباب من المشاركه في
التظاهرات
حرم المتهمون من مقابله محاميهم وتم
تمثيلهم بدلا من ذلك بمحامين عينتهم
المحكمه
حملت نظام الايراني منذ سبتمبر طالت
اعتقال نحو 18,000 شخص ووجهه اتهامات الى
36 منهم على الاقل بارتكاب جرائم ما
يعاقبوا عليها بالاعدام روان حمزه العربيه